هربا من شبح الموت والدمار لجا اكثر من
100 الف سوداني الى دول مجاوره
سيدفعهم 700 الف اخرون وذلك بحسب توقع
الامم المتحده
اما داخليا فتخطى عدد النازحين
334 الف سوداني توجه اغلبه من الخرطوم
مركز الحرب الدائره الى القرى والولايات
المجاوره جنوب السودان وتشاد ومصر ابرز
وجهات اللاجئين بحكم الحدود المشتركه
الحدود المصريه التي استقبلت اكثر من 15
الف لاجئ سوداني بات معبر قسط الاشكيت
البري القريب من مدينه حلفا السودانيه
المعبر المفضل للاجئين السودانيين
المتجهين الى مصر وذلك بسبب انعدام
الخدمات في الجانب السوداني من الخيار
الاخر معبر ارجيه بالاضافه الى وجود
القنصليه المصريه التي تصدر تاشيرات دخول
المواطنين من الرجال السودانيين من سن 16
عاما وحتى 50 عاما
فاستقبلت حتى الان اكثر من عشرين الف لاجئ
سوداني اغلبهم من اقليم دارفور وهو نفس
عدد اللاجئين تقريبا الذين فروا الى جنوب
السودان معظمهم من السودانيين الذين
يعيشون بالحزام الفاصل بين الجارتين
بالاضافه الى ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه لاجئ
اتجهوا الى اثيوبيا عبر معبر الجلابات في
ولايه القضارف العدد الاقل كان الى
جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
1500 لاجئ نظرا لكون الحدود بين البلدين
مغلقه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات